when you
subscribe
to the criminal criminal world
you know the rules i mean if you're
going to be a rat and roll over and put
people away you're going to be shot dead
[Music]
i'm bobby cummings obe
i was known as a notorious villain
my business was crime i've never been a
gangster never ever wanted to be a
gangster i'm just a businessman whose
business happened to be crime i like
coming on lad's bible
because he don't glamorize it and i
don't glamorize crime i tell him how it
really is that is why i choose to come
here if i didn't like it i wouldn't come
because i'm still quite arrogant
serious question i like serious
questions
while you're giving this man a platform
the amount of her and his stress they
have caused to others is so vast what
about the victims absolutely right why
give us a platform because we won't give
you bullsh we will tell you exactly for
those who give that life up will tell
you exactly where it leads and so what
we're doing by de-glamorizing crime is
making sure young people don't come into
that world and create more victims of
crime that's why i'll get the platforms
like led's bible to be able to tell all
those kids who think it's glamorous no
it ain't
and hopefully the next victim the crime
don't happen again
so i hope that answers your question
peanut
and that's your name i'm not taking the
mick out yet
do you ever get recognized in the street
or anything like that every five minutes
yeah i went down to brighton and i had
so many people popping selfies off
uh come here is it are you in yes i mean
my body coming just like can we have a
selfie with you i'll blame bloody lads
bible for that mate and all the internet
yeah
probably it's like thomas shelby from
oblique binders but of course a bit more
of a gentleman well thank you ever so
much i'm glad you think i'm a gentleman
uh tommy shelby i'll i'll
see the excerpts of
peaky blinders i think it's quite good
but it's a bit over exaggerated you know
why are you going to blow up offices for
people in it because they dissed me
that's the new one this means disrespect
me no i'm going to go in i'm going to
take money off them if i'm a villain i
ain't going to blow up something that i
can take money out of so it's a bit
far-fetched i looked at a film one's
called lock stock
and i kept laughing and my wife said
what you laughing at i said if i mean it
was like that i said it's comedy i said
you know i said i think it's a send up
someone's like smoked a bit of pot i
said never laugh and she went well
what's it really like
and that's what i said i said it's
nothing like that it's a nightmare world
and you've got to be top dog or you work
for someone who's topped up
little people the most dangerous i mean
the crows weren't big people
frank mayor frankie fraser weren't a big
guy charlie richardson won a big goal
the top guys
and i think it's because you're smaller
and you've got these big guys you're not
going to roll around on the floor with
them because they're going to hurt you
so you shoot them it's a lot easier and
it goes away you know and people know
well i can have a fight but i don't want
a bullet in me so
they stay well out your way so no i'm
i'm grateful for for you saying that to
me that i'm a gentleman
thank you because i hope and i try to be
bobby seems like he was genuinely a
scary man
i thought that was my business
my business weren't going around and
going hello can i rob your bank you know
it was
terrorizing people basically and also
kept people in check you know
don't forget i was dealing with very
dangerous people at the time he wanted
to take my business so yeah i had to
scare him the only way i scored him i'd
be more violent than i was and i knew
i'd pulled a trigger on him so yeah yeah
i do genuinely like in that world being
a very scary man in fact i want to be
the scariest man i've ever met i want to
be their bogeyman that they'll go to bed
at night worrying about because that was
what kept me in power and that's what
earned me money so yeah i did like it
then do i like it now i don't scare
people now
and on days did you also wear a suit
all the time i think that's part of the
of the of this of the scary thing
well no i mean especially yeah mind you
i would be scared if i make the tax man
but why i've got to sue it's because i
used to like zoos and that's when i
stopped cutting people up and all that
because you just get blood on my suits
and i'll go and buy a new one so i
thought it's easy to shoot them that way
i'm going to get nothing on me i did
violence for a living i never ever did
bad manners i was brought up properly i
never did bad minutes and i don't like
people with bad benefits i don't want
them in my company they start getting
rude they gotta go well done me show
them i mean they just gotta get out of
my company i don't want it but no that's
what the business was scary
you don't step on my toes we're all
right you step on my toes then we got a
problem
i like how he says multiple times that
being called a gangster offends him and
then led bible call him a gangster in
the title of the description well
lucky enough i like the people that have
left bible they've become almost like
friends um i don't take offense because
you know i say i'm a businessman his
business crime i never wanted to be a
gangster but i suppose members of the
public would call me a gangster who
would you call gangsters out of the
other people gangsters are people got no
manners they're loud they want everyone
look i'm here i'm here if you're in the
crime business earn money you don't want
to you know you don't want to advertise
it because you're going to get arrested
so these people they we call them
wannabes they all hang together all want
to be gangsters
and
they're just rude people that ruin
everyone's party get drunk abusive
putting coke up their nose to make them
feel better well i suppose it's good
entertainment if you if you don't want
to go to the circus go and stand in the
booze with all that mob and you sit
there and you'll have a good giggle you
know you're living there and thinking
yourself i'm earning all the money and
you've got please arrest me officer
because i need to get some credibility
no can't be in my company that's a
gangster
how he can justify the difference
between killing a competitor to killing
an innocent person i imagine just
killing your co-worker in the office and
saying that's just business well i bet
most you have considered killing your
co-worker in the office because they get
on your nerves there's people get on my
nerves and i think oh if i was back in
the day i could put a bullet for a uride
but what you've got to realize is that
in the criminal world we live in a
different world to everyone else all the
rest of you people are part of the crowd
in oxford street we don't know what you
do we're not interested in what you do
when you
subscribe
to the criminal just the criminal world
you know the rules i mean if you're
going to be a rat and roll over and put
people away you're going to be shot dead
if you're going to steal off another
criminal you're going to get cuts a
piece of shot in the leg so you all know
the things you can do and the things you
can't do and you never miss about a guy
who's in prison you never mess about his
wife you're going to get shot you know
they're going to do you or they're going
to catch you to pieces because we won't
want it done to us but you've got to
think about a competitor in an office
you're just competing for promotion i
mean our world if they're go if you
think they're going to snitch you're not
i want to kill them you've got to kill
them because otherwise they're going to
put your weight for 30 years that's the
difference
they should get bobby to talk to kids in
schools and stop them going into crime
be amazing to see what advice we would
give them well i'd do that
i did that what did
so i can say to kids no i've done it i'm
not telling you not to do it but expect
this at the end of it
when you do it so it's your choice so
you need 30 000 pounds and if there's
three of them that's 10 grand each oh
we've had the right touch then they get
nicked
and they get 10 years of peace right so
it's 30 years
it works out a thousand pound a year
they're better off on the dole
why i'm opening up a project now it's
called land koi
and i'm opening up a project for kids
so they can learn about fish they can
learn about to build ponds so they're
learning bricklaying all sorts of things
it's no good training them at the end of
it you've got to have a job at the end
of it because otherwise there's a drug
dealer on a corner or someone who's at
it on you know in the street will go how
much you're getting on the dole come up
with me you get 400 quid a week kids all
want nice clothes they all want the best
things because we're in a designer for
our way world so they want to look as
good as the next guy so they're going to
go with that guy whether it be drugs
whether it be firearms whether it be
burglary because they want to be the
same as that kid who's got it and they
haven't got the means to do it because
we ain't got the jobs to give them
and people write them off i don't write
no one
every child to me is worth saving
why does this get awarded with an ob
hardly a good role model
right they'll put it this way to you
you've got psychologists you've got
social workers you've got all these
people that read a book about our lives
and then they become specialists at it
why do i get an ob because when i talk
to any of the kids i talk to any of the
people i talk to they know i've lived it
so the reason i've got the oba is
because i care about our kids i care
about the mothers and living in poorer
states i care about my people my people
working class people because your
government does nothing for them and
they've got titles like lords
i'll give it a nickname once i'd said
yes of commons was the house of common
and the house of lords should be named
the house of frauds because that's what
you got in there i'm for real they know
what i've done i've never said i didn't
do it i've always said yeah that's me
i'll go and talk to it every one of them
fiddling their expenses having parties
even your prior prime minister have been
parked on your ass you're paying for the
bulls right so i think i'm a pretty good
role model and why i've got the ob is
because it was recognised and i think
also there was a bit to it because i
told the truth and i talk the truth
about politicians and everyone else they
thought give him an hobby and we get him
into our camp best thing they ever done
because now give me credibility to tell
even more the truth and expose them to
what they are we all know about my dirty
laundry you don't know what they've done
in there and i would have so i think i'm
a better role model than that
does it upset you to eat something like
that
no because
the guy's asking a question it's a
legitimate question i don't mind people
ask me a question i don't even mind
people slagging me off you know because
everyone's been told their own opinion
as i said my life is very simple i don't
judge people by their colour i don't
judge them by their sexuality i don't
judge them by their religion my life is
so simple are you a good person or are
you a bad person if you're a bad person
i'm the last guy you want to make
because you get rude with me i'm not
going to be nice to you right if you're
a good person you're welcome in our
company any time so no this is a paul
dudson right has asked the right
question i had the right to ask that
question and now i've answered it for
him
i wonder if he realized how popular he
is on here does he even know what lead
bible is well yes i do know what led
bible is and i didn't realize until i
was told and how many followers i have
and it's five five and a half million do
you read the comments under the videos i
always read the comments on facebook i
always read what people say because i
really because i need to know whether
i'm getting it across whether i'm
getting my message across that crime
don't pay i think
the reason i'm popular is because people
can ask me questions
and
i just tell you how it is
i had to go through hell to appreciate
evan made me tear up because the
relatable still getting better i love
the cut of this man's jib what's the jib
it's i don't actually know what that's
like the sort of uh the way in which you
speak no i know what jib is
you should dress
yeah yeah okay
prison never broke me
right i was locked in blocks maxim's
crew never broke me what brought me was
when my daughter died
um
because at first you know all them years
i thought i was invincible i couldn't be
here i couldn't be touched
well when my daughter died
i'd gone straight you know i was out
working i was waiting under a pound a
week packing shelves in tesco's in the
night shift i thought why me now why
didn't you do this years ago when i was
doing bad stuff i'm doing good stuff now
you know and i sat there just looking at
and i couldn't come to terms with it and
it was really heavy duty for me the
hospital was closing like to walk
through the baby intensive care unit and
i saw them little babies and their
parents all at the windows you know
looking at their kids
and i don't know what happened it was
really weird
i thought why not me
you know dear people would never have
known i've hurt a lot of people why not
me you know i wouldn't wish this the
pain i was thinking i wouldn't wish it
was like someone punching you in your
chest and ripping your art out and if
anyone ever says to you even if they've
lost a child i know how you feel
they don't because it's so personal that
pain is so personal and that's when i
knew i was vulnerable you know i knew
and in fact you know
by her death really brought back my
humanity and got rid of the brutality i
don't want to let no one anymore you
know i don't he looks glamorous
but the old saying is you eat the meal
you pick up the bill you go at it and
you're going to get a 30-year sentence
don't know when you get it because you
know the rules you know that's how it
works
he didn't have to go through hell he
chose his path look at the evil
is it
probably right you're probably dead
right on that one yeah but you know
i chose it absolutely chose it and i
loved it when i was doing it all right
so if that's evil that's good but also i
didn't put a whip across a kid's back to
cut cotton for me i didn't go and sell
people into slavery
and i didn't try and sell a heroin opium
to the chinese but your government done
that all their ancestors done that so if
i'm evil well then you've just met the
devil it's called the azir parliament so
yeah i'll book you right it was evil and
what i did i did chose the path
should they make the movie about bobby
well they're doing so son out in america
i'm meeting him in
october november to look at the scripts
and sign the contracts
if i want to sign the contracts it's all
according to
the script so um yeah
are you going to be a movie star now no
i'm not being a movie so i've got
plastic tape and a ball did they we're
gonna get someone answer my name that
looks apart i mean there's not gonna be
a lot of people going wow and he lovely
i'll fancy him no that gets that please
go to get something like brad pitt or
someone went down and i'm really gonna
be happy then because i'll go yeah
in my previous life what was that you
know so is it going to be like a dog
like it's going to be actually no it's
going to be it's not a documentary it's
going to be an actual film yeah yeah i'd
like to play i think they should in my
later years they should get phil collins
we go at the same addresses and a lot of
people say you look like him so yeah and
then everything i've done i can blame
him on phil collins so um who would you
want to play you
i don't know there was a guy who'd done
an interview with you
a nice young guy he was with a girl um
tom holland spider-man guy and he sees
my thing while he was waiting
and uh
i smiled because it was at the end of
his cart bless him and he's talked to a
five pound english accent well educated
i like it when you have like a gangster
come on
yeah well that's a very different vibe
today what's it like when you interview
that gangster though terrifying yeah
and i'd love to see him be bobby
cummings through a cockney accent i'd
get a buzz out of that and say you want
to play hard parts you play that part
mate talk
with a cockney accent and do in film do
what i've done when i was your age that
sort of thing because i would have been
his age when i was doing it i'd love to
see him play that that'd give me a kick
we see him next time we'll we'll tell
we'll tell you yeah tell him say play
bobby cummings yeah
give you the connection
i've got the police outside right now
well they've nicked me for everything
i've done so i'm sweet
i'm good boy now i've even got my
catholic medals on me to prove it i've
taken an assistant governor hostage in a
maximum security so everywhere i go i've
got loads of prison offices around
because they think i'm going to take
another one right and six or ten man
unlock ten men unlocked there you go
what does that mean that means only only
ten officers in riot gear with a
governor an so and a po can open your